they were once nearly extinct but over the last
two decades wolf populations in Idaho Wyoming
and Montana have grown to nearly 3 000 thanks
to a 1995 reintroduction plan carried out by
Yellowstone National Park their return has been
a giant success for the conservation movement but
a Relentless headache for ranchers last year we
reported from Yellowstone's border where tensions
had reached a fever pitch this morning we take
you to Colorado where some wolves have moved in
on their own and others are about to be released
by public mandate amid Hope For Less conflict and
more compromise every morning the typically quiet
and empty grasslands west of the Colorado Rockies
are awakened by the routine sound of Don gittleson
feeding his cows he makes a living raising cattle
for grass-fed beef and sells selectively bred
Bulls to producers so it's just you wow 1200 acres
in you when the cows go up there yeah I'm the one
that puts them up there and I'm the one that gets
yourself in an average year there's a lot to do
to keep the ranch running but at the end of 2021
A new challenge was piled onto his workload so
the first time I saw the mail he was up on the
mountain that was the first sighting when was
the first kill so that was I think about the
22nd of December last winter seven of his cattle
were killed by wolves four of which he received
compensation for from a government program he's
Limited in what he can do to defend his herd
because this particular pack is protected under
The Endangered Species Act so if I catch him in
here at night I can chase them now I can't injure
him so I have chased them about three o'clock in
the morning this is the first pack to settle
into Colorado in at least 70 years scientists
traced the female wolf from Northwest Wyoming 400
miles north of the gittleson Ranch these guys they
travel oh they travel they definitely travel
the pack caught the eye of Colorado University
wildlife biologist Joanna Lambert who studies
wolves and coyotes across the country she's
well aware of cases like gittlesons where wolves
take down livestock instead of natural prey yeah
it's a worst case situation A worst case scenario
absolutely ranchers who are right there between
those public lands and the private ones or
probably the ones who are going to get hit yes
absolutely but life without wolves has its own set
of problems deer and Elk population skyrocketed
after wolves were wiped out in the early 20th
century it influences all of the other aspects of
that biological community that are and it's even
you know has consequences for erosion in areas if
there's massive overgrazing and coyote populations
have been cropping up in unexpect expected places
so basically while wolf numbers were going down
coyote numbers have been going up they are in
every state except for Hawaii they are in every
major Metropolitan region of the United States or
in Manhattan research like Lambert's showing that
returning wolves helps rebalance the ecosystem
spurred a campaign that led to Colorado voters
deciding to reintroduce them to the state in 2020.
we can take politicians out of the picture and
create a science-based plan that safely restores
wolves to our ecosystems let's restore the howl to
Colorado the proposition passed marking the first
time a species would be introduced by ballot a few
dozen wild wolves will be captured likely from the
Yellowstone area and released on public land in
Colorado beginning as early as this December of
course I didn't vote for it I thought it was a bad
idea you're left to deal with it yeah it is what
it is the pack that settled around the gittlesons
ranch are unaffiliated with the reintroduction
plan they showed up on their own but if gittleson
has one hope it's that the wolves that are
reintroduced are not treated so preciously so if
they become a problem like here you can handle it
they can be put down yes some scientists including
Lambert agree with gittleson to some degree so the
experimental status is sort of the gray in a Land
of black and white yeah it renders the whole kind
of experiment which essentially reintroduction is
right it renders it more adaptive and more of a
compromise yeah and a compromise ultimately we've
all got a kind of cooperate have conversations
about what we are and are not willing to lose
that conversation continues to grow louder as
plans to conserve all kinds of native species pick
up steam the goal is where possible restore what
we've lost some habitats are forever lost to
urbanization but there are still millions of
Acres of protected land the scientists see
a potential as homes for beavers bears and
wolves are we attempting to rewild the West we are
indeed at least in the areas that can support that
and there's so many issues here one this is
highly emotional for ranchers I mean you can
talk science and data but when they are witnessing
kills of their very precious sure I mean we saw
the close-up right there absolutely but then
two you have learned behavior and these wolves
are very smart when they learn that cows who are
less rambunctious than say elk they know that's
you know an interesting kill and you really see
how delicate the ecosystem is here you move one
little thing and all the repercussions
and the Ripple effects it does and you
know we're trying to write a hundred years of a
mistake and that's hard to do stunning landscape
though one story a big shout out to Kathleen
secum and uh Ben McCormick well done this